all good things must come to an end and
that includes betas if you've been
enjoying the battlefield 1 beta you
might want to squeeze in as much time as
you can before it closes on Thursday
debated began last week on August 30th
for Battlefield insiders and opened up
to the public on the 31st until now dice
and EA had not revealed an end date for
the beta yay did not say exactly when
the beta will end on September 8 but
will report back to you if the developer
announces a specific end time along with
this the developer disabled around timer
for conquest matches no changes have
been announced for rush the battlefield
1 betas other mode as announced
previously EA is giving away a
battlefield one open beta dog tag to
everyone who reaches rank 15 and plays
on four different days battlefield one
launches on October 21st for xbox one
playstation 4 and pc what are your
thoughts on the beta will you be picking
up this or titanfall 2 in October let me
know in the comments below and for all
things gaming stay tuned to gamespot